Hi, my name is Kyle Mcllhone and I’m from
Canada.
So I first started studying acting at Dawson
College and I did that for two years.
And after that I worked from three years in
Montreal, mostly in theater.
And then I moved here to New York to enroll
at The Neighborhood Playhouse and I graduated
in 2015.
And since then I’ve been working here.
And this year Karan [Choudhary] and I produced
NEW YORK’D and it’s doing very well in
film festivals and we’re very proud of it.
[Scene to NEW YORK’D movie]
[Text appears and delivery man shows Karan
the phone]
“Hey, look…my boss” Kyle Mcllhone as
The Delivery Guy
“Alright, I’ve also got to go.”
Replies Sean
“Just pay me and deal with your own personal
problems later, huh?”
“My personal problems?
You’re the one who is causing these personal
problems.”
“What?
Are you blaming me for getting yourself locked
out of your apartment?”
“You are the delivery guy.
You’ve got one job to do.
If you had done your job like you are supposed
to.”
“If you’d cook your own food like you’re
supposed to…”
“You make a living because of people like
me.”
“And you get to enjoy hot food in bed because
of people like me.”
“Yeah…where is it?
Where is my hot food?”
“I just want to get my money and get out
of here.”
The biggest problem for me has been the business
of acting.
I got into acting because I was passionate
about acting.
But then when you choose to make it your career,
you have to buy into the business of acting
which an be better headshots, really going
somewhere where you have to pay a lot of money
for that.
Getting a reel, paying someone for a reel.
Then agents, managers, networking with them,
going to classes to meet casting directors,
so many more.
And social media is a big one.
And that clashed along with my passion because
I’m not really that kind of person who is
good at that.
So how I’ve been dealing with this problem
is I’ve been dealing with my own projects
because that way I can get my own reel, I’m
learning, I have something to talk about,
I am doing something, I’m not waiting by
a phone, I’m active.
As an actor you want to keep yourself tuned.
You want to be always acting more and more.
And when you start off you think you’re
going to do that through actually auditioning
and doing stuff that you will be paid for,
you know?
Not always the case.
And so you can get in the rhythm of (I think
someone once said) An Auditioning Actor.
Like someone who is good at auditions but
when it comes to a full script, it’s actually
foreign to them because they haven’t done
it for awhile.
I’ve been fortunate I think because something
I consciously do is to alway try and act so
I’ve done a lot of plays for free which
I’m very grateful for in the end because
it kept me fine tuned.
I’m working with people who have worked
longer in the business.
I’m learning and not only that I’m being
challenged with a new role and all of that.
And that I think his just good for my mind,
I think it keeps me happier.
Thank you so much for watching this interview
and my question would be to you guys if any
of you who are actors or producers, what problems
you come into?
What problems have you deal with the business
and how have you learned?
Thank you!